bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 24 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré des journalistes de la rédaction
mais également de nos invités vont le
monde suit avec les titres de cette
édition une crèche vivante pour célébrer
noël enfants et adultes ont participé à
cette initiative du club de saint
quentin qui s'est déroulée à l'église
saint-pierre du lac à
montigny-le-bretonneux plus d'une
vingtaine de messes seront célébrées ce
soir sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines un message de paix dans un
contexte particulier après les attentats
de paris en novembre dernier le père
bruno valentin curé des paroisses de
voisins-le-bretonneux et montigny le
bretonneux sera en plateau pour nous en
parler
et enfin qui sont les sportifs yvelinois
qui ont marqué l'année 2015
réponse dans la chronique sport allie la
môme a dit champion d'europe de boxe
sera notre invité et pour commencer nous
allons parler météo vous avez sans doute
remarqué la douceur particulière en ce
début d'hiver cet hiver les températures
sont supérieures à la normale avec
environ 4,4 degrés en plus il s'agit de
l'hiver le plus doux jamais observé
attrape par exemple depuis 1926 et à
l'observatoire de paris montsouris
depuis 1872
le dernier record de température été
constatés en 1934 et 1974 avec 2,8
degrés au dessus des normales
saisonnières
une douceur également attendus pour le
reste de l'hiver cela s'explique et bien
évidemment à cause du réchauffement
climatique
le phénomène el niño et surtout à cause
d'un phénomène métérologique provenant
du sud ouest les détails avec frédéric
et mizrahi au micro de sephora mamani
l'hiver est doux parce que nous avons
des deux flux de sud-ouest à répétition
depuis maintenant deux mois donc des
flux qui viennent l'atlantique
subtropical de la région des açores
donc si nous amène sans arrêt des masses
d'air extrêmement douce et lisse yves
une illustration de la situation
météorologique qui persiste depuis maman
de moi avec toujours ces flux de
sud-ouest qui nous vient
depuis depuis la région des açores et
qui vont qui remonte très très loin vers
le mort jusque vers la scandinavie on a
aussi des températures beaucoup plus
élevé que la normale est à l'occasion
des fêtes de fin d'année le club saint
quentin organiser une crèche vivante ce
week-end à montigny le bretonneux
cette année pas de cortège d'animaux en
raison des attentats dont une pour des
raisons de sécurité les familles sont
restées à l'intérieur de l'église saint
pierre dulac à fanny pour des ions et
camille lambert
ici pas de son ton mari joseph et les
rois mages sont joués par des enfants
l'église saint-pierre du lac de montigny
le bretonneux à proposer une composition
vivante de la crèche dans une ambiance
familiale
l'idée c'est de marquer le temps de noël
à travers un temps festif et convivial
pour tous vraiment ouverture sur la
ville organisé par les enfants du club
saint quentin qui est à assen d'accueil
et de loisirs
donc à but éducatif et chrétiens six ans
déjà que le club saint quentin offre ce
spectacle l'occasion aussi pour les
enfants de comprendre la nativité
on a fini sur de petites histoires pour
introduire la crèche et la naissance de
jésus en juillet va ya mais via les
bergers carrier ya les fromages et
d'ajouter le cadeau il est né le divin
enfant
enfin presque en attendant on patiente
avec des chants de noël
et en ce jour de noël nous recevons le
père bruno valentin curé de la paroisse
de montigny le bretonneux et de
voisins-le-bretonneux bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
que nous venons de le voir justement le
sujet le reportage sur la crèche vivante
c'est une de vos initiatives
pourquoi avez vous voulu organiser ça
c'était voilà un petit rappel une fête
chose pour pour le voltaire la crèche
est une très vieille tradition ça
quasiment neuf cents ans aujourd'hui ça
a été inventé par servant d'assise et
quand il l'a inventé il a inventé comme
une pièce de théâtre et non pas comme
les petits personnages en terre cuite
que tout le monde connaît et donc nous
aussi on a voulu se réinscrire dans
cette tradition qui consiste à faire
jouer l'histoire de noël pour tout
simplement la rendre accessible à tous
et notamment aux plus jeunes aux enfants
un resto on l'a vu il n'y avait pas
d'animaux justement dans la crèche par
mesure de sécurité on est dans un
contexte assez compliqué au vu des
attentats qui se sont déroulés le 13
novembre dernier à paris donc le
contexte un peu tendu il y aura des
mesures de sécurité ce soir avec les
différentes maladies sont organisées oui
bien sûr la préfecture de versailles a
donné des consignes précises pour que
tout se passe dans les conditions de
sécurité maximum et donc dans les
yvelines comme partout en france
toutes les messes de noël se dérouleront
dans la plus grande sécurité
c'est quelque chose que vous craignez
dont les fidèles vous parle il nous
interroge il nous interroge pour savoir
si la sécurité est assurée non je
parlerai pas de crainte
il n'y a pas de peur simplement les gens
veulent savoir si on prend nos
responsabilités ce qui est le minimum
est ce que justement aller voilà les
églises sont plus surveillés dans cette
période pour la messe de noël mais aussi
pendant les vacances de noël s'il ya des
mesures à respecter pour les fidèles par
exemple oui qui sont au fond des mesures
de bon sens ce que demandent les
autorités civiles c'est tout simplement
que chacun ouvre l'oeil et soit attentif
au comportement anormaux aux vêtements
anormaux bagages anormaux et surtout ce
qui nous et redis c'est ne pas hésiter à
signaler au curé aux prêts qui sont là
tout ce qui peut nous sembler étrange
alors je le rappelle cet entretien a été
enregistrée ce matin pour que vous
puissiez justement à les faire aller
messe de noël sont alors comment vas tu
comment vont-elles se passer y en a
plusieurs vous allez faire voir un
espèce de circulation plagiat bah oui
parce que vous avez nous on tient à ce
que tout le monde de ceux qui le
souhaitent puissent célébrer noël donc
on commence dans l'après-midi dans les
maisons de retraite dans les différentes
maisons de retraite
la messe est proposée tôt ensuite en
début de soirée il ya des messes pour en
particulier les plus jeunes les enfants
les familles et se prolonge jusqu'à
minuit pour les poulets ya des méthodes
différentes pour les plus jeunes pour
les enfants proposer des choses
différentes on essaie d'adapter les
choses oui en reprenant une dimension de
deux jeux de théâtre et puis en mettant
les explications à leur portée alors du
coup il va y avoir de demi douzaine de
metz qui va être faite ce soir ça ou sur
saint quentin en yvelines dans son
ensemble il ya plus de vingt-cinq messe
célébrée sur ma seule paroisse montini
voisins y en a cinq déjà alors est-ce
que vous allez forcément donner une
dimension à spéciale à cette messe de
noël
oui oui bien sûr parce que je crois que
l'enjeu
si chaque noël c'est noël chaque année
mais avec tout ce qu'on a vécu depuis
depuis ces dernières semaines
je crois qu'il ya un enjeu important à
corriger peut-être un certain nombre
d'aidés figuration de dieu qui ont pu
être données par ce qu'ils ont fait ces
attentats parce que il en fait au nom de
dieu et on peut pas perdre ça dur quand
même
ils prétendent en faisant sa montre et
qui est dieu et l'enjeu de noël cette
année c'est évidemment de montrer que
dieu c'est tout autre chose
si dieu devient homme se fait un petit
bébé c'est qu'il est tout autre chose
que ce visage de haine de violence qu'on
a voulu nous montrer
c'est une discussion que vous engager
avec vous fait des ajustements par
rapport à ces attentats et par rapport à
la religion qui peut aussi être effrayé
parfois ce côté là justement avec le
terrorisme oui on en parle beaucoup
comme d'un défi qui est lancé à nous les
croyantes c'est à dire nous disons
connaître dieu nous disant être en
relation avec dieu
alors qu'est ce que nous en savons qu
est ce que nous sommes capables d'en
dire d'en montrer est d'abord de notre
façon de vivre parce que les gens
n'attendent pas d'abord des discours
mais des engagements concrets et donc
ici à saint quentin on va avoir à coeur
dans l'année qui vient de vivre l'année
spéciale qui s'ouvre pour toute l'église
catholique à partir du mois de janvier
qui est une année de la miséricorde le
défi que le pape françois nous nous
lance c'est de montrer que le vrai
visage de dieu ses tendresses proximité
attention aux plus fragiles délicatesse
les uns avec les autres
c'est ça le vrai visage de dieu et notre
défi c'est de le montrer et donc l'année
2000 tiens voilà sera donc l'année la
miséricorde il va avoir des choses qui
vont être engagées différemment peut
être aussi haut dans vos mais cela va
changer quelque chose
oui dans la façon de prier mais surtout
dans la façon de faire on va être
attentif à développer davantage
peut-être qu'on ne le fait jusqu'à
maintenant encore tout l'engagement
caritatif
la solidarité c'est la fête noël c'est
la fête la plus importante pour la
communauté chrétienne vous avez beaucoup
plus d'affluence ce soir est ce que
c'est le moment de rappeler aux gens
voilà le sens religieux de cette fête
qu'on oublie parfois oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'il est toujours bon de le
rappeler mais faut pas non plus sombrer
dans un pessimisme un peu noir
moi je crois que les gens ils savent ce
qu'ils viennent fêter et que au fond
même s'ils viennent le fêter sur le mode
de leurs liens familiaux sur le mode une
solidarité plus grande c'est pas un
contresens par rapport au message
proprement religieux de noël qui allait
vous allez faire passer un message à
spécifique par rapport aux attentats
mais aussi par rapport à la solidarité à
la charrette oui absolument
chaque année noël est l'occasion pour
les catholiques de se mobiliser beaucoup
sur ce terrain de la solidarité et cette
année plus que puisque d'habitude encore
est ce que justement il ya valeur des
choses organisées tout au long peut-être
des vacances de noël que vous faites
avec la paroisse justement à la station
connaître des personnes âgées ou autre
alors il ya des choses qui vont se
réaliser qu'on était mise en route en
amont par exemple la paroisse se
mobilise chaque année pour fournir aux
détenus de bois d'arcy des cadeaux
qu'ils puissent eux-mêmes offrir à leurs
enfants
voilà comme ça on veut soutenir le lien
parental en fait des personnes détenues
en leur donnant les moyens de se
manifester comme papa auprès de leurs
enfants
donc ça ça fait quelques semaines qu'on
a déposé à l'aumônerie de bois d'arcy
les cadeaux qu'ils vont pouvoir donner à
leurs propres enfants
et puis pendant les fêtes un certain
nombre de repas pour les personnes
seules sont organisées on attend sans
personne à l'école du lac à voisin le
jour de noël on attend plusieurs
dizaines de personnes à guyancourt au
cap st-jacques le soir du 31
il ya effectivement toutes sortes de
repas notre notre grand point de
mobilisation pendant les fêtes elle même
c'est la solitude justement par rapport
à la suite vous faites peut-être appel à
des bénévoles à des gens qui peuvent
venir nous aider pendant ces fêtes
données vous même peut-être ce soir
absolument toutes les personnes qui ont
envie de donner un peu de leur temps
toutes les personnes qui ont envie
simplement de vivre s'est fait un peu
autrement sont les bienvenus très bien
merci beaucoup un père bruno valentin
d'être venu sur notre patrie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et qui souhaite
un joyeux noël et bonne fête merci
et on ouvre à présent une page sports la
19e édition du 4l trophy est programmé
du 18 au 28 février prochain cette année
plus de 1300 équipage composé
d'étudiants se sont inscrits pour ce
raid automobile humanitaire cette année
une guillon portoise laetitia des l'on
prendra le départ de cette course qui
relie la france au maroc un reportage
signé michael elle me d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude à une aventurière des
temps modernes laguian courtoise
laetitia des landes 24 ans étudiante en
deuxième année de master s'est lancé le
défi de disputer la 19e édition du 4l
trophy une course d'orientation
automobile exclusivement destiné aux
étudiants qui relie la france au maroc
pour s'inscrire à l'épreuve les
participants doivent collecter en
moyenne 7500 euros pour couvrir les
frais d'inscription et la préparation du
véhicule
l'aide de sponsors est donc
indispensable on a voulu en fait
s'adressait à des grandes entreprises
donc au début on a eu beaucoup de nos en
fait énormément de noms donc on a on n'a
pas baissé les bras mais c'est
démotivant
et puis dans un jour voilà on a eu
beaucoup de oui et puis voilà avec le
contexte plein de choses
enfin la persévérance au final et on a
rempli notre objectif
la compétition est organisée du 18 au 28
février l'illinois se partagera cette
expérience avec sa camarade de classe
anaïs charting on va tourner
régulièrement tu as trois heures chacune
à chaque fois pour pour se répartir le
temps pour éviter cette pratique juste
avant en fait on assimile kilomètres à
faire pendant dix jours
du coup ça fait une moyenne de 600
kilomètres par jour donc on va alterner
voilà des qualités fatigué on alterne et
puis après bah oui on va vivre ensemble
au quotidien on aura une petite ans donc
on va dormir ensemble tous les soirs
sous la tente pour participer à cette
course humanitaire qui consiste à amener
50 kg de fournitures scolaires au maroc
et des étudiantes ont acheté une voiture
qui a déjà deux 4l trophy à son actif on
a un moteur quand même relativement
simple on a notre batterie notre
l'équipe de refroidissement on a deux
ventilateurs pour refroidir le moteur
pendant le raid on aura peut-être le
filtre
à nettoyer ce qu'il sera rempli de sable
et puis pour le reste tout est
impeccable pour cette première
participation les deux étudiantes vise
le haut du classement
oui je l'espère on est on est motivés
ont des aventurières et on va rien
lâcher
au total plus de 2000 étudiants sont
attendus au village de départ à biarritz
pour participer au 4l trophy 2016 et
nous recevons à présent sur ce plateau
notre journaliste sportif et michael me
de raw pour la dernière chronique sport
de cette année 2015 bonsoir michael
alors qu'est ce que vous nous avez
préparé pour cette première chronique et
bien je vais vous prêt vous proposer un
top 3 des sportifs y vino a qui ont
marqué l'année 2015 ça n'a évidemment
pas été facile florane ils sont nombreux
à avoir écrit l'histoire du département
cette année puis la rédaction de tv fil
78 à trancher entre un pur et position
on retrouve ligne montrent un françois
pervis vous connaissez forcément son nom
florane vince la star de l'équipe de
france a brillé lors des championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste
une compétition organisée en février
dernier au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le cycliste de 31 ans a fait vibrer les
5000 spectateurs de l'enceinte sportive
en remportant le kilomètre le keirin
pour l'épreuve du kilomètre françois
pervis s'est élancé en dernier avait
devancé de 87 centièmes de secondes
l'allemande joachim et l'ours dans
l'épreuve du keirin il monte un s'était
montré irrésistible en devançant le néo
zélandais edward dawkins et le mal et à
wang avec ces deux victoires pervis a
gagné le coeur des français nous
l'avions interrogé à la sortie des
épreuves du championnat du monde en
février dernier j'ai envie de dire un
grand merci parce que c'est exceptionnel
c'est vraiment incroyable
tous les jours c'était c'était bondé
même les jours de semaine moi j'ai eu le
droit à une dizaine de tours ils ont
fait la ola pendant une dizaine de tours
toujours ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur
le dernier virage dans mon kilomètres
j'étais planté de 71 jeu tiré le frein à
main et si j'ai gagné c'est vraiment
grâce à dieu parce que mon deuxième
dauphin il est à huit centièmes de
seconde derrière moi vous pouvez même
pas vous imaginer huit centièmes ce que
ça représente c'est rien du tout et il y
aurait pas eu public
je sincèrement j'aurais pu gagner c'est
vraiment lui confie la différence dans
le dernier tour françois pervis compte
depuis cette année 2015 six titres de
champion du monde
et ce n'est pas fini florane l'année
2016 pour être encore plus belle il
pourrait pourquoi pas une médaille d'or
olympique à rioux l'été prochain ont
bien mais ce n'est pas fini on lui
souhaite évidemment peut-être danser la
samba à copacabana avec l'or autour du
cou
on remonte à présent dans le classement
michael à la deuxième place on retrouve
les handballeuses de médecine bretagne
c'est un exploit quasi historique pour
les îles montagne et pour le handball
yvelinois l'équipe senior est monté en
alors nationale une cette année dix ans
après avoir à avoir atteint ce niveau
les joueuses coachée par philippe
étrange se sont imposés en juin dernier
lors des barrages de nationale 2 contre
nîmes à villefranche sur saône près de
lyon les y montaient n'avait réussi à
dominer leur adversaire le score 30 à 26
7 victoires a ponctué une formidable
saison c'est pour cette raison que
montigny figure dans ce classement
l'entraîneur philippe l'étranger c'est
au micro de fanny bourdillat belle année
difficile mais bon je pense qu'on a
mérité notre hôte monte vu au match de
barrage mais je crois que les filles le
staff technique et le bureau sont très
honorés de de cette place c'est positif
j'espère que ça va on va y rester
maintenant il faut qu'on se construisent
au tout autour de ça et qu'on grandisse
grâce à ça cette montée récompense
également l'histoire de tout un groupe
la plupart des filles jouent ensemble
depuis trois saisons on écoute philippe
les tranches
c'est difficile dans un sport collectif
de mettre une ou deux joueuses bon je
prends soin fanny jean baptiste gabriel
parle were seront tirés l'équipe en tant
qu'ancienne je dirais 1
et puis les pizzas les jeunes pousses
qui conçut se mettre à niveau pour pour
terminer à cette place là le groupe
devra se remobiliser pour cette fin de
saison les i montagne connaissent des
difficultés en cette première partie de
championnat après avoir remporté deux
victoires en trois matches en septembre
les promus se sont effondrés et pointe à
une inquiétante 10e place mais rien
n'est perdu pour le maintien
effectivement amicales rien n'est perdu
tant que la cloche n'a pas sonné
justement on passe maintenant à notre
grand gagnant de l'année je crois que
j'ai donné un petit indice dans
l'attraction vous ne m'en voudrez pas
vous êtes tout pardonner florane je sais
parce que c'est vous
le numéro un désigné par la rédaction de
tv fil 78 et élan courtois il fait de la
boxe il a construit sa victoire en
s'entraînant de façon intense au palais
des sports d'el en cours il a remporté
la ceinture de champion d'europe des
super moyens en mai dernier en battant
l'espagnole hilario chez lui je veux
bien sûr parler daddy la mauve a dit
bonsoir adila bonsoir vous êtes donc le
sportif évinois de l'année que
représente pour vous ce titre c'était
une belle année une très bonne année
pour moi le fait d'avoir déjà ce titre
européen a été un objectif déjà atteint
en début d'année et puis le fait de
pouvoir garder d'avoir toujours ce titre
est d'être champion toujours européen
même en fin d'année c'est c c'est super
donc on va revenir sur ce fait marquant
cette victoire en espagne contre hilario
il arrive a commenté nous cet exploit ça
a été beaucoup beaucoup de sacrifices
sur des entraînements ça a été un combat
aussi très intense hilario été un très
grand boxeur bon boxeur il faisait
partie aussi il a fait partie de
l'équipe nationale d'espagne il n'a pu
participer à aux derniers jo
c'était quelqu'un il fallait pas prendre
à la légère
et puis
la victoire nous et quand même a été
favorable vous étiez outsider sur ce
combat
ouais ouais et finalement vous avez
aussi à renverser la vapeur
exactement donc à défaut de ne pas
l'avoir fait justement de ne pas avoir
fait ce de ce combat dans les yvelines
on est comme revenu avec la ceinture
l'arrivée de la chercher du mois en
espagne et c'est une victoire aussi très
important dans votre carrière vous aviez
perdu il ya deux ans et elle est mis du
temps à vous remettre dedans parce que
personne vous voulez vous affronter
ensemble voilà jeunes un jeu compliqué
j'avais j'avais rencontré james cigales
qui était champion olympique 2008
pour mon premier titre européen j'ai
perdu
au point au 12e round par point décision
des juges et
deux ans plus tard peut-être un an plus
tard propos justement je deviens
challenger européen
et puis ça a mis du temps avant de
d'organiser le combat mais ça c'est fait
donc deux ans
voilà deux ans en boxer mais on se
préparait toujours mais du coup on en
pense quoi
dans ceux de ce genre de situation quand
vous gagnez la ceinture quand vous avez
la ceinture entre les mains qu'est ce
qui se passe dans votre tête
quand j'ai eu la ceinture entre les
mains ça a été pour moi déjà un
soulagement
à réconfort et puis je voulais
absolument cette ceinture voilà c'était
le dernier objectif que j'avais pu me
donner avec mon entraîneur
donc on tourne farrugia avec qui j'ai
commencé justement ma carrière de boxe
professionnelle une fois que j'ai eus
bas je me suis sentie capable de faire
encore plus donc aujourd'hui j'attends
du plus je suis prêt à aller plus haut
que cas championnats d'europe les
spécialistes de la boxe estime
qu'aujourd'hui vous est peut-être le
meilleur boxeur en france ça vous flatte
oui beaucoup oui beaucoup pourtant enfin
le meilleur je sais pas si je suis
meilleur c'est vrai que dans 5 à 6 par
rapport aux autres boxeurs en ce moment
va dans ma catégorie forcément le bon
j'ai été
champion de france j'ai pu être
aujourd'hui je suis champion d'europe il
ya là il y en a d'autres mais bon
aujourd'hui je suis champion d'europe
froid que dans ma côté ma catégorie en
france et deux titres le pelouse le plus
important est question des effectifs
maintenant les mondes mais j'espère pour
2016 et on se reverra une fois qu'on l'a
il conserva sont descendus à peut-être
aussi aurélie aussi défense de ceinture
c'est ça on défendra sa ceinture si on
peut faire
depuis raku ça serait pas mal maintenant
c'est vrai que je vois plus haut que
donc ça serait gardé cette ceinture en
larmes est en jeu et puis aller encore
plus haut un monde si ainsi possible ça
ça ça se prépare
le problème le problème avez vous avec
vous c'est que personne ne vous
affronter c'est ça le problème
ça peut être difficile ça peut être
parfois difficile c'est vrai que moi
j'arrive pas forcément le comprendre je
suis prêt toute l'année donc et vous
avez 35 ans ouais la boxe vous comptez
faire rentrer de la boxe pendant de
nombreuses années jusqu'à l'âge
nombreuses années tiff pas spécialement
pas force pas spécialement en nage pas
en âge je me dis vraiment je suis tant
que tant que ça me plaît je prends du
plaisir à faire ce que je fais j'y vais
donc on entendra encore parler d'adil
hamouma dit pendant encore quelques
années
ouais ouais c'est sûr et 2016 qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
plus du coup la firme mondiale ceinture
mondiale sentir mondiale pour 2016 et ça
serait ça serait une très bonne chose
très bonne et très belles choses en tout
cas on vous le souhaite a dit l'homme
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci d'être
passé sur ce plateau je le rappelle vous
êtes champion d'europe des poids super
moyens et donc maintenant sportif
illinois de l'année 2015
félicitations à gré d'ailleurs on a un
petit cadeau pour vous donc vous voilà
la coupe très bien trop facile
merci c'est super voilà vous pouvez le
mettre sur votre cheminée en anglais de
l'année mais est bien merci beaucoup
d'être venu michael c'est la fin de
cette édition c'est la fin
quelle heureuse chronique pardon je n'ai
plus qu'à vous souhaiter de bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année on se retrouve le lundi 4
janvier c'est du jeu dans mon agenda
flora pour les sept filles sport et le
jeudi 7 janvier pour votre chronique
sport passer d'excellentes vacances
merci vous aussi je vous souhaite de
bonnes vacances également et de bonnes
fêtes
adila est justement avant les vacances
de noël le collège champollion à voisins
le bretonneux organiser un événement de
solidarité
les bénéfices seront tous été reversés à
l'association c'est que du bonheur
hospitalisé en novembre ils ont organisé
une collecte de jouets puis ce vendredi
deux séances de mini zumba ont dédié le
collège et permis de récolter des dons
nouvelle fois pour l'association on
écoute les élèves de ce collège qui ont
organisé l'événement
on a fait de la sonde ba il m'a donné 3
euros pour les enfants qui qui sont
malades puisque c'est important des bad
tant que c'est pour des gens qui ont mon
sens là si c'est pour des hôpitaux
je pense que c'est important c'est pour
offrir des loisirs aux enfants ce qu'ils
étaient avant les vacances c'est sympa
et en plus d'être avec d'autres élèves
et c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis pour
ce dernier journal de l'année 2015 à
suivre vous retrouvez à 20h30 toute la
rédaction pour une émission spéciale
fêtes de fin d'année avec des chroniques
et plein de surprises ne la manquez pas
je vous retrouve l'année prochaine le 4
janvier pour la première édition du 7 8
le journal de 2016 je vous souhaite donc
ainsi que toute la rédaction un joyeux
noël et de très bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année